thank you
this is a long program we got to get
through this guy's I want to first say
it is great to be back on campus this is
uh this is a special place this is
hallowed ground for me and it is
wonderful to see all of you young
wonderful columbia college graduates
you're going to rule the world i also
want to embarrass somebody sydney where
are you sydney marie where are you there
you go my campaign manager I have
pictures of Sydney when she was a very
young child I'll be willing to show
everybody at the conclusion of the
ceremony but it really is great to be
home and I do really mean home I was
born just a few subway stops from here
in the Bronx and grew up across the
river in Queens I went to Stuyvesant
High School in Manhattan and then 47
remarkable years for as an undergraduate
then three is a law student this campus
was my home this city this university
and especially this College mean
everything to me I lived in Carmen Hall
my freshman year
karbonn hall room 301 a and I I have to
tell you when i found out that there's
air conditioning in carmen l I couldn't
believe what's that's mr. president hot
and cold water
now I think you guys have it pretty easy
unlike every other freshman I was not
wide eyed when I ride to campus on
move-in day growing up in New York I
knew I had it all figured out what what
could cook what could Columbia possibly
surprise me with then I met my roommate
he was a very nice guy who was more
interested in altering his consciousness
on a frequent basis
more interested in that than in
contemporary civilization now as your
attorney general that's all I can say
about that it's except that he didn't
last more than two months after he moved
out and I got a new roommate this time a
and this is all true this time a 16 year
old computer whiz and yes there were
computers back then this poor student
was a genius and a genuinely nice guy
but he had absolutely no social skills
and no interest in anything other than
computers before long he was gone too
and I was one of the few Columbia
freshman with a single I could not have
chosen for more tumultuous years to be
on this college's campus than nineteen
sixty nine to nineteen seventy-three the
Vietnam War the rise of Black
Consciousness the women's movement the
stirrings of Gay Pride the feeling that
anything was possible that the world
could be changed all made my for college
years exciting and memorable those years
and those memories draw me back to
Morningside Heights on a frequent basis
no matter physically where I am I was
among a large group of students who felt
strongly about the way we thought the
world should be and we weren't afraid to
make our opinions heard I did not take a
final exam until my junior year at
Columbia we were on strike every time
finals seemed to roll around
but by that third year we ran out of
issues I also recall one day when we got
together and decided to peacefully
occupy one of the campus offices we felt
passionately about the need for a place
where black students could gather and we
went ahead and staged our sit in this
became what then was known as the black
students lounge and what was then
Hartley hall the person who we had to
negotiate negotiate with and whose
office we also occupied later for other
reasons was Dean Henry Coleman in the
ultimate display of hutzpah I later
asked him to write my law school
recommendation this being Columbia of
course he agreed he was a great and a
generous man this college allowed an
impetuous testosterone lace youngster to
express himself in ways that other
institutions would have considered
unacceptable but not Columbia and this
is why I love this place my time at
Columbia was among the most meaningful
and formative of my life my memories of
those years and the valuable lessons
that perhaps I didn't feel fully
realized I was learning at the time are
still with me every day and so they will
be for you as well I want you to look
around at this crowd that your friends
and your fellow classmates it may feel
to you that as though these years or
these days or your final ones together
and it is true that most of you will
never again be students again together
but I am here to tell you that this is
just the beginning of a long and I am
confident fruitful road that you will
travel together I have spent 30 years in
law enforcement public service and the
private practice of law at every step
along my professional path I have
encountered men and women of and from
lumbia those sitting around you this
morning will populate and enrich your
lives again and again and again you will
find each other's at the highest
echelons of Corporate America in
elective office as judges lawyers
doctors directors of nonprofits
engineers and teachers you are now and
you always will be brothers and sisters
in the Columbia family and I welcome you
in to that family membership has its
privileges but I really want to talk to
you today about the family obligations
and the family traditions now although I
hope that a good number of you will
continue your studies I know that
tomorrow will be the last day that some
of you will spend on an academic campus
as a student you may never sit through
another lecture or pull another
all-nighter fueled by nothing but
caffeine and fear and I know that as you
pack your bags load them into your car
or van and drive off toward whatever
might come next the last thing you want
to know about is a new bond of
responsibility but that is what you must
do you are Columbia men and Columbia
women i am talking talking specifically
about the obligation to be a servant for
the public good now you may define the
term public servant narrowly as an
individual he chooses to run for office
or to work within government but there
is much more to it than that public
service is not a career path to be
chosen or avoided nor is it an
extracurricular activity for which only
some will find time for in their busy
lives I challenge each and every one of
you today to recognize that you're all
public servants with contributions to
make to your communities and to this
great nation regardless of your career
choice you must give the people the
benefit of your education the benefit of
your expertise and serve them Abele and
faithfully in
whatever you do whatever your job find
the time to do so it is what Columbia
people have always done from this day
forward you must do your part to improve
the world around you let us never forget
that our country has only grown stronger
the words of our Constitution have only
reached their full measure because of
previous generations of Americans who
have embraced the obligations that came
with opportunity from George Washington
who risked his life on the battlefield
for an untested experiment called
Liberty to Abraham Lincoln who risked
the very life of our union in the name
of freedom to the Reverend Martin Luther
King who gave his life for the dream of
equality you must embrace your
responsibilities indeed welcome them
with the same spirit of passion and
dedication that you have shown in your
successful academic careers you must
dedicate a portion of your energy and
compassion to those less fortunate you
must give to the children in our cities
who are starved for the kind of
attention you can rather easily give you
must help those who have lost their way
but who can be helped by the direction
that you can easily share you can reach
out to schools youth centers and
churches mosques and synagogues to
spread your knowledge and your good
works and if you don't find yourself on
the frontlines of change then help out
those other unsung leaders already at
hard work in our community those people
who truly deserve our respect the people
who work hard and who play by the rules
who teach our children who minister to
us when we are ill who go to work every
day in search of a better life these
people are too often ignored make sure
they are recognized and find ways to
help them we should glory in their work
and in the positive effect that they
have we must find our heroes in the
people who truly contribute to the
betterment
of our communities and we must each
strive to emulate and support their
heroic efforts however and whenever we
can the person who can and is willing to
teach a child to read is infinitely more
valuable to our society than someone
with a good jump shot support that
person and better yet be that person now
I have no doubt that
I have no doubt that over the course of
the past few months as the end of your
college career has drawn closer you have
had more than a few worried
conversations with your fellow students
friends and family George and Stephanie
and other parents here they're worried
that Sydney and others are coming home
you have wondered about your future
prospects in an economy that seems to be
leaving all Americans no matter what
color their collar facing Lee
increasingly long odds and difficult
times you may even be compelled to think
that your class has gotten a raw deal
well let no one tell you that your path
will be easy but let me tell you that
this difficult time for our country can
and must be an opportunity for you
pursue that advanced degree train
yourself in diplomacy law education or
foreign service set your sights beyond
the careers that seem to offer the
greatest financial rewards to the ones
that will reward your soul and enrich
our world
as graduates of this great institution
your task is not primarily to do well
but to do good I say without fear of
hyper but I / believe that sitting
before me today I see the future of our
nation I have seen the impact that a
group of talented energetic men and
women with a great work ethic training
and drive can leave on the world what
excites me though is not your obviously
your obvious abilities but your
possibilities the prospect that you
might devote yourselves to the task the
building for yourselves a better country
a better world now while I believe that
my generation has done far more good
than bad the current state of the world
proves that our work is incomplete I
implore you not to let an ounce of your
promise go unfulfilled I call upon you
to aim higher and do better than my
generation and those that came before
you owe nothing less to yourselves to
your families and to the side to society
that has watched you nurtured you and to
help you flourish I urge you to lead by
example I challenge you to show the
world that a new generation of Americans
is prepared to embrace the gifts and the
consequences of the great power that you
will inherit there is not one path to
success in your career where I believe
that many of you will find success in
all sorts of ways that we cannot even
begin to envision today just like my 16
year old freshman roommate who mastered
computers and put himself on the front
lines of an industry that most of us
didn't even know existed but let me tell
you something else from experience even
when you succeed there are going to be
some rough days your task then is not
only to be true to yourself during those
difficult times it is also to continue
to be loving and dedicated to your
families and your communities as well I
leave you with a few words written by
Alfred Lord Tennyson
which are found handwritten in the diary
of my most famous predecessor attorney
general robert f kennedy Tennyson rights
ah what shall i be at fifty should
nature keep me alive if I find the world
so bitter when I am but 25 we may not
know with clarity the test this future
will bring but graduates as you dive
headfirst towards tomorrow I call upon
you never to loosen your grip on hope
the optimism that seems to come
naturally with youth need not be lost as
the years pass hope is a precious but
enduring thing not a blind or passive
hope but rather a confident hope indeed
a certain hope that through our actions
big and small positive change is not
only possible it is inevitable this is
what has driven the best from Columbia
in the years passed and so it must guide
you in the years coming the time is now
the responsibility is now yours good
luck and Godspeed